You ever smell a scent and get reminded of a very specific dessert?
Olivia Bell Elixir has top notes of raspberry and cocoa butter.
This warm and fruity mix immediately brings a smile to my face
and makes me think of a little chocolate cake and raspberry coolies.
After making my raspberry coolies,
I chopped up some chocolate
and let that melt with some butter on the stove
while I got started on whipping up some eggs and sugar
with a pinch of salt. Once my chocolate had melted,
I put some flour in my egg mixture
and poured my melted chocolate all up in there
before gently folding it in until no streaks remain.
I poured that in my little ramekin,
let that bake, and topped it with my raspberry coolies.
This is exactly what the scent reminds me of.
Thank you, lancome,
for partnering with me on this.